doggies pups what are they doing when
you're not watching okay you're free I'm
gonna give you a treat today I'm
answering this question by spying on my
own dog coronavirus has forced us
non-essential workers inside encroaching
on our dogs domains so I'm doing this
because I'm a BuzzFeed producer Rasta
come up with videos around her own home
well technically my parents home
I left my small Brooklyn apartment along
with my husband and dog to shelter in
place at my parents home in Florida they
also have two dogs so today I'm gonna be
spying on the dogs and uncovering all
their secrets
let me introduce you to the dog crew
there's Lucy that's my dog she is a lady
she's tiny but she's very alpha then
there's Chandi she's a big girl she
loves food and she loves pets and then
there's Jack who is on constant guard
from intruders or boats
what are we barking at absolutely
nothing yeah I'm a little nervous I'm
gonna find out that my dog Lucy does
really gross things or weird things that
I didn't know about but maybe she's just
gonna be really boring there's a really
high possibility of that but there's
only one way to find out I'm gonna get
up are you wait all right I'm gonna
follow you around today what do you
think of that day he started out fine
breakfast was the main focus watch me
get made and then ravenously consuming
it then the day took a turn for the
worse
thunder lightning a dogs were standing
me other than vacuums and fireworks
so obviously thunder outside the dogs
are scared and they're now indoors are
you guys scared they are all huddled up
on top of my mother so I guess they just
judged her as the best care taker which
I mean make sense for Jack and Chandi
but was a little insulting to see Lucy
also thought that I mean when you can't
go outside and you're stuck in your home
then there's even less to do I mean I
tried to get them to go outside they
wouldn't they did not want to go outside
at all you guys I know your good side
now that they're all stuck inside it's
like what are they gonna do I kept
imagining what Lucy was thinking you
know why is the sky shouting at me will
I ever get to leave the house again will
they ever get to pee again with two
months of staying at home and not going
out I've asked the same questions I mean
at least I had something to do which was
spy on them spying requires distance and
it's hard to get that when you're
sheltering in place with someone it's
like Lucy was always aware of my
presence it's like she had some sort of
sixth sense I'm you know it could have
been just the sense of smell that could
have been the sense that she was using
to know I was around but I felt like
they were spying on me back like
sometimes I would be following Lucy but
she would then start following me so
then I was like who's spying on you okay
it's anxiety inducing to not know what
the future holds and pretty early on I
could tell it was getting fussy
what are you bored at first I think she
was just acting
a little bit looking for attention is
this what you want
she kept rolling her ball under the
couch and then barking until you know
someone would get it for her
by early afternoon she was picking
fights with Jack Lucy was not a good
girl
but I get it being so close you're bound
to get into stupid fights with your
roommates then as it got dark it seemed
like the rain might stop
but then bang more thunder more
lightning at this point my mom had left
for a pharmacy run so the dogs
surrounded my dad on the couch
they must see him as the second most
powerful human of the household and I'm
probably number three maybe it was a
tough day but there were some reprieves
dinnertime Treat time those are the same
times I would look forward to as a human
they found a few things to do chandi
likes to watch TV so she watched some TV
she wasn't really fan whenever there was
a dog on I assumed you think she would
have done better in the part and so she
could have barks out the window jealous
rage the days ending they've been cooped
up inside Lucy and Jack are at odds and
I realized a few things isolation was
definitely negatively affecting the dogs
and also I'm a horrible spy that's why I
decided to give myself another day of
spying on them and I'm really glad I did
because the next day was beautiful it
was like night and day there was so much
more energy I think they had been cooped
up so Lucy was running around like crazy
dogs the dogs that had a lot to do there
to catch up with the neighbor dogs
I assume discussing the neighborhood
gossip perhaps and yeah you have to find
your own world
and they certainly did they could burn
watch a lot Lucy found dead poems that
had fallen down from the storm the night
before out of the neighbor's yard I
guess it's like trash to treasure you
know there's a lot of watching out the
window it's the delivery person coming
and also I get that because right now
we're only going out like once every two
weeks to the grocery store so anytime
there's a package it's like the most
exciting thing Mike and I decided to
take them all on a wall you know because
walking a dog is an excuse for us to get
some fresh air we even ran into some
very friendly dogs and we of course
social distance spine was easiest when
they were sitting and sunbathing spine
was hard when I caught Lucy doing
something naughty and I had to intervene
she rolled in some dirt crap got it all
over herself they all had to get
showered and I understand her not
wanting a shower I mean I've been
showering less you know we're just stuck
in one place what's the point so after
the tensions from the day before Lucy
and Jack decided to resolve their fight
and make up it might look like Lucy's
bullying jack but I think that's just
how they play an even big sandy joined
in so everyone was having fun good so
after two days of spying what did I
learn I learned the dogs can get
depression anxiety just like humans so
while we're all cramped up at home
remember to check on them I also learned
that they eat a lot of bugs and grass
when you're not looking
who's gross it was way more than I
thought the biggest thing I learned is
that companionship is so important
during tough times like this and I'm
lucky that I have Lucy I think she feels
the same way raelia
[Music]
or maybe not
you see you see you see
[Music]